this video is brought to you by Dollar
Shave Club get a shave starter set for
only $5 and check out their great
holiday gift sets after that the restock
box ships with full-size products at the
regular price go to Dollar Shave Club
calm /ba graphics to get started some
weeks ago we ran an episode about the
Vatican City State on our sister channel
Geographics which you should definitely
subscribe to there's a link below in
that video I mentioned to one of the
tiny state's most peculiar residence and
many of you asked me to expand on his
life here on the Biograph exchange and
Mort the most experienced and prolific
Exorcist in force at the Vatican between
the start of his career in 1986 until
shortly before his death in 2016 father
a Mort claimed to have exercised 300
subjects per year so let's get into it
then how did Gabriela or Morse become a
priest and more importantly an exorcist
Gary le a morn on May the 1st 1925 in
Medina northern Italy now famous for
being the home of Ferrari Modena also
had a high concentration of alleged
witches and wizards especially from the
15th through the 18th centuries some of
them were just experts in herbal
remedies but they still had to face the
local Inquisition active from the 13th
to the 18th century one of these occult
individuals deserves a special mention
father Gama campaña a renowned local
priest campanha who as an exorcist but
also a womanizer a sorcerer and a
necromancer
he was duly tried by the Inquisition in
1517 we don't know if young Gabriela was
aware of these stories what we do know
is that he grew up in a household that
was both religious and involved in
politics
his father was an early supporter of the
People's Party of action inspired by
Catholic ideals and the precursor to the
eventual Christian Democrat Party in
1943 Gabriela turned 18 and he was
drafted into the fascist army but he
went AWOL and joined a resistance unit
headed
a Catholic activist for the following
two years amour fought against fascist
loyalists and German occupation forces
rising to the rank of battalion
commander within the resistance that's
equivalent to an army major and had done
all of this by the age of 20 it's
reassuring to know that your local demon
hunter was also handy with a rifle and a
Sten submachine gun a most reported
being arrested and sentenced to death
more than once but he always managed to
escape after the end of the war the Mort
was awarded the war Cross for military
valor after returning to civilian life
Gabriela moved to Rome to study law he
also became active in politics in 1947
he joins the recently founded Christian
Democrats as vice Secretary of the
potties youth organization the secretary
in charge was one Guinea or andreotti a
controversial figure who later became a
cabinet minister and eventually prime
minister McGarry Ella didn't pursue
politics since the age of 17 the Mort
had considered joining the church and so
after earning his law degree he enrolled
in seminary to become a man of the cloth
in 1954 Gabriela attained a second
degree in theology and was ordained as a
Catholic priest
[Music]
during his first years in priesthood
father
immortan did not practice exorcisms nor
was he probably even aware of these
rituals at that time the number of
exorcist priests in Italy could be
countered on two hands however a Mort
did dedicate himself to some of the most
miraculous supernatural and even
controversial aspects of the faith a
long devotee of the Virgin Mary amor
studied the Marian apparitions in
modern-day Bosnia he firmly believed
these to be true life events a point of
fact not endorsed or agreed upon by all
clergy members in 1959 he visited
another side famous for miracles
attributed to the mother of Jesus Fatima
in Portugal in a spectacular and
surprise father a morte organised a
pilgrimage in Reverse he arranged for a
statue of the Virgin to travel from
Fatima to all of Italy's main cities his
old pal andreotti
now Minister of Defence assisted by
loaning Ahmad some military transport
helicopters it's a good friends during
this tour father remorse took the statue
to the convent of Padre Pio or father
Pius now Saint this mystic friar is
widely believed to have performed
miracles during his lifetime and after
his death it was also beset with
stigmata unexplained bleeding marks that
appear on the ribs wrists hands or
thieves matching the wounds that Jesus
Christ received on the cross it was
father Pio who first introduced father
amor to the mysteries of the devil and
its presence among humans often the
Prince of Darkness would torment appeal
disguised as a huge snarling black dog
while the friar prayed alone is
convinced all the Helmand would attack
him forcing him into vicious all night
long fights father Pio died in 1968 and
was canonized as a saint in June of 2002
during the ensuing years father a mortar
did not have direct contact with any
demons the closest he got was his
acquaintance with father Candido a
mantini who for much of the 1960 70s and
80s was the only sanctioned Exorcist in
Rome but things are about to change
in 1986 father and Mort was 61 an aged
coast to retirement for most people and
yet his true career was only just about
to start
On June the 6th 1986 father a morte was
summoned for a meeting with Cardinal
Pilate the highest-ranking
clergymen in Rome besides the Pope
during a casual conversation but let's
he asked if a lot knew father a mantini
The Exorcist as a Mort answered that yes
he had met him previously he noticed
that Pilate was scribbling on a piece of
paper at the end of the conversation the
Cardinal handed him a note it was an
official appointment as assistant to a
man teenie and just like that a mortared
become assistant Exorcist for Rome which
essentially made him the deputy chief
Exorcist of the Vatican
he understood immediately that he was
going to become more than an assistant
he would soon become a man teenies
successor as the current chief Exorcist
was in poor health
a man teeny held on for another six
years dying in September 1992 from 1986
to 1992 a more to learn from his mentor
all the tricks of that terrifying trades
that is the casting away of demons are
now ask you to step into Gabriella's
shoes as I take the role of Anna and
teenie and take you through a quick
apprenticeship of how to become a Demon
Slayer first lesson what is possession
[Music]
according to the official Catholic
catechism demonic possession is the act
by which the devil a demon or a spirit
takes over a victim's physical activity
as well as their mental and spiritual
energies by exerting physical violence
upon the hosts which manifests for the
victim MERS illness or pain the demon
can coerce humans into committing unholy
sins so what exactly is the ultimate
goal of these malignant entities in most
cases it's just to spread chaos for the
sheer pleasure of it the possession
cases that L&T nians immortals involved
themselves in mainly it belongs to a
category defined as peripheral
pathogenic by modern anthropology
anthropologist i am luis makes a
distinction between central and
peripheral types of possession in the
case of central possession a member of
the religious elite becomes possessed by
spirits during an official ceremony in
which he or she fulfils a political
religious or moral function peripheral
possession on the other hand indicates
an invasion of evil spirits unwanted
immoral dangerous anthropologist Emma
Cowan further sub classifies peripheral
possession into executive and pathogenic
executive possessions involve the
complete replacement or transformation
of the hosts personality with that of
the invading entity in pathogenic cases
the spirit or demon will cause abnormal
and deviant behavior illness pain or
misfortune to the victims while their
identity is largely intact
it's the alternating of normal and
abnormal behavior that leads the victims
social circle to seek help the world's
largest religions all have their
interpretations of what entities may
cause these peripheral pathogenic
possessions according to the Talmud
sacred book of Jewish tradition
possession is called de book this is
when the soul of a dead person is
grafted onto a living person's soul in
Islam those who are greedy for earthly
pleasures have low self esteem or
struggle for acceptance may be possessed
by a Jim according to the Quran these
are entities made of smokeless scorching
fire and not necessarily malevolent in
Hindu lore unwelcome possessions
manifest as physical or mental illnesses
mainly affecting women and children
these are caused by a number of evil
forces such as Buddha's or ghosts
cartels blood-sucking witches pisacas
flesh-eating demons
and well many more going back to
Catholicism the Catechism identifies
possessing entities as either the devil
himself or much more commonly his demons
these are fallen angels which means that
their strengths intellect knowledge and
cunning are superior to that of humans
nonetheless they are still God's
creatures and are ultimately subject to
his will that's why an ordained member
of the church can perform exorcisms
these are simply defined as act soar
rights by which priests use their
authority to demand that a person or
even an object is rid of the influence
of evil father a mantini introduced his
pupil Gabriella to the strictly codified
procedures to conduct an exorcism as
defined by ecclesiastical law and the
Roman ritual this is the official
collection of sacred rites and prayers
to be used during the sacraments but
before you can start to exercise the
patience how can you be sure that a
demon is lurking within well just before
you get into all of that I just want to
take a quick moment to thank today's
sponsor Dollar Shave Club see my thing
it a bit odd that I would advertise a
shaving company because clearly I have a
beards but I still have to shave I just
shaved my head instead so I used to use
an electric razor but it never really
got that close to a shave then I moved
two blades but I kept cutting myself
because I buy the cheap ones then well I
bought the really expensive ones and
they did a great job but they were
really expensive but then then I found
it on a shave club with Dollar Shave
Club quality doesn't come with a crazy
price tag and I mean really who wants to
spend quite so much money on razors they
aren't just usually crazy expensive and
it's not just shaving Dollar Shave Club
also covers all of your other grooming
needs shower or or care deodorants all
there anyway it's the holiday season so
Dollar Shave Club also have gifts
available there are gift sets and gift
cards so if you really want to be a
legend to a friend or family member get
them the ruble on show I'm not sure if
I'm pronouncing that right but it's a
combo of a robe a blanket and a poncho
yep so Dollar Shave Club is a great
place to find a gift for your
significant other maybe a dad or brother
or just a friend it's amazing stuff look
all of this great stuff is super high
quality this is the executive handle
it's really nice and weighty obviously
high quality blades come with it just
like that
also dr. Carver's shave palette who does
this stuff it's just better than fine
forget fine get this to go to
dollarshaveclub.com /bi graphics to get
started today for just 5 pounds also
check out those holiday gift sets once
you've started a restock box ships with
full-size products later at the regular
price let's go back to it
[Music]
immortal urns how to approach every
potential case of possession with a
process called discernment first
patients must present with clear
symptoms
besides irrational changes in one's
behavior including performing acts of
violence and self-harm there are some
physical symptoms the whites of the eyes
may appear red as in cases of
conjunctivitis the pupils will be
excessively and constantly dilated the
patient's face will appear longer and
darker than normal so far all of these
symptoms are compatible with known
physical and psychiatric ailments but
others stand out much more clearly some
patients would display immense
inexplicable physical strength their
voice may become unnaturally hoarse and
deep they will speak or understand
languages previously unknown to them
such as Latin ancient Greek or Aramaic
they will react violently to the
presence of sacred objects or the
mention of religious figures in extreme
cases just thinking about Jesus or Mary
may throw patients into a fit of rage if
people carried these symptoms immortan
an entity would organize a prayer
service with them known as a diagnostic
exorcism if patients were to react
adversely is suggesting an actual
possession The Exorcist would refer them
to a medical team for further evaluation
this is a very important step as father
amor sends all exorcists in general
recognized the importance of proper
psychiatric evaluation if no medical
remedy were found for the victims
suffering then the priest would then
decide whether to proceed with the
exorcism and seek permission from his
local bishop by shadowing a mantini
father a more perfect at his exorcism
rights according to Roman ritual these
must be conducted by a priest in Latin
or another Vatican approved language
while standing on sacred grounds the
Roman ritual is rigidly codified priests
are meant to follow a preordained
sequence of prayers Psalms and
excitations intended to expel demons
from the hosts body immortal angelee
followed the ritual during a
apprenticeship but he eventually
introduced some personal touches for
example he always wore a purple stole
which he ensured was wrapped around both
his and his patients shoulders he boys
made sure he was carrying holy water and
bearing a medal of Saint Benedict of
Nursia the Saints is mostly known for
his lasting influence on monastic life
in education but he is also famous for
defeating Satan on at least three
occasions over time immortalized that
more than 90% of his cases that made it
to step 5
turned out not to be real possessions
that is why he developed a further
screening method which works only once
an exorcism was underway and Mort claims
that during the ritual many patients
would close their eyes during specific
prayers in turn amorous at their eyelids
forced open in the case of real
possessions the eyes appeared completely
white in an interview with British
broadcaster jar's brandriss a more
specified that if the pupils are
completely rolled upwards then the
demons in possession are scorpions if
looking down they are servants a Mort
did not elaborate on this distinction
but serpents or snakes are a common
incarnation of Satan or his demons in
Christian art and literature scorpion
demons are more interesting though as
they belong to the Mesopotamia mythology
that predates any description of
judeo-christian demons
it was a Mesopotamian demon Pazuzu that
appeared as the main antagonist in the
movie The Exorcist after a period in
which father a more closely shadowed his
mentor he finally had the chance to
perform his first exorcism as the lead
this case related to a fourteen year old
girl who after attending a satanic
ritual in central Rome immediately
presented with symptoms of possession
her parents took her immediately to
Amenti knee but unfortunately the lead
Exorcist was ill Ahmad stepped forward
in a rare instance of disobedience II
disregarded the discernment process and
immediately started the ritual in later
interviews he claimed that the girl was
healed after one single session he
explains this by citing the immediacy of
the exorcism which had prevented the
demon or spirit from taking root or
burrowing inside the victim this was an
exception in most cases patients were
taken to a mantini and a morte only
after months of suffering from
possession symptoms according to a
mort's new theory this
enabled invading spirits to settle
inside the hosts this demonic
fortification required exorcisms to
continue for multiple sittings at least
an hour long over the span of months or
even years until a patient was
eventually liberated his liberation and
given father a more to be can
increasingly confident about his odds of
victory with each passing exorcism the
teaching of an aunty knee was that
regardless of their power demons will
ultimately succumb to the power of
Christ if properly channeled through an
exorcist father immortal once told
journalists that the devil may win some
battles even important ones but remember
he will never win the war while the
remorse indeed waged a constant war
against the legions of Hell since his
appointments in 1986 until his death in
2016 the chief Exorcist dealt with more
than 300 cases of possession every year
that's a rough total of 10,000 alleged
possessions requiring him to perform
about 70,000 exorcism sessions however
father reports always admitted that the
actual cases of demonic possession were
in the hundreds not in the thousands in
most cases exorcism didn't work and
patients were referred back to
psychiatric care and eventually cured by
other means in actual cases of
possession father a morte estimated that
90% of them reduced the patient's
exposure to a spell a curse or a satanic
ritual amor technologies that most
self-described witches wizards
clairvoyance or Satanist priests are
harmless occult enthusiasts at best or
mundane scammers at worst however he
believes that a small minority of them
actually do have dark powers so what are
the effects of confirmed possession on
its victims well let's take the example
of one of the mort's youngest patients a
boy of 11 halfway through the ritual the
boy or the demon within flew into such a
fit of rage that he had to be restrained
by seven grown men and even then the boy
managed to send them flying through the
room viola manifestations and attacks
are not uncommon which is why exorcists
often deploy physical restraints on one
occasion a patient succeeded in
attacking a more directly delivering a
kick so strong that broke his leg the
priest can't wear a cast for a month
most attacks directed at the priests
to take a different form and that's
spitting this is a manifestation of the
scorn and spite felt by demons against
the Exorcist and his prayers in some
cases the projectile was more than just
saliva and one particularly tough ritual
the Mort went to cover the patient's
mouth while she was foaming and spitting
and when he retracted his hand he said
that he found it filled with metal nails
this was not surprising to her Maud
spitting or simply producing metallic
items in the patient's mouth is a common
trick used by devils to hurt and scared
a victim's he recalled patients slowly
ejecting from their mouths large metal
spikes shards of glass or even a radio
which came out one piece at a time
during his career father a Mort had
frequently spoken about the film The
Exorcist while praising it for raising
awareness about the practice of exorcism
he pointed out that the ritual used was
not the correct one and most of the
symptoms displayed by the victim were
exaggerated no the head can't spin 180
degrees and no people can't bend over
backwards and walk around like spiders
however victims can contort in unnatural
ways angles and shapes but they are
unlikely to crawl like arachnids how
about green projectile vomiting while
vomiting does happen but never with such
force and can patients levitates well
actually a morte confirms that this does
happen although he only experienced it
twice in 30 years on another occasion he
witnessed something even more chilling a
possessed old lady was able to walk on
walls like a reptile and lastly the
patient's voices sound double as though
there is more than one entity within
well this could be the most interesting
one of all the Mort always maintains
that Satan or his demons do not like to
talk this is because they hate being
detected however when they are
discovered they may engage in short
dialogue with the exorcist usually
limited to verbal abuse or curt answers
to the priests questions the entities
may not reveal their name when questions
if they do they often claim to be Satan
or Beelzebub what they will easily
reveal is how many of them there are
within the host sometimes three five
seven perhaps even a legion of demons
are within even then though double or
multiple sounding voices is extremely
rare but not impossible for a full
account of the battles of father amore
ii only advise that you pick up one of
these several books he published on his
experiences including an exorcist tells
his story my battle against Satan or
memoirs of an exorcist now
is fair to wonder if the Exorcist in
chief of the Vatican has ever felt fear
during his daily occult struggles even
if one does not believe in demons we are
still talking about confronting patients
who are deeply disturbed and potentially
dangerous often several times a day
journalists have asked him many times if
he's scared of Satan and his reply
absolutely not it is him who is afraid
of me Father remorse has always had an
open and positive relationship with the
press a channel that he sees as
importance in raising awareness of
exorcism he believed that prior to the
three most recent Pope's Vatican
leadership had not done enough to
support exorcism in the public
consciousness it is perceived as an
ancient and outdated practice of the
church rather than a noble very real
fight against the devil immortus has
never been shy about his critical view
of top church officials either he has
accused them of trying to replace the
Roman ritual of exorcisms with less
powerful variations and of trying to ban
diagnostic exorcisms a key step and the
discernment process in 2012 father Ahmad
successfully prevented both changes from
taking effect two years later he scored
another victory receiving an official
acknowledgment from the Vatican for the
International Association of exorcists
which yet co-founded in 1990 these
conflicts with the Vatican have been
exacerbated by a series of interviews in
the 2000s in which father a morte stated
that the Holy See had been infiltrated
by demons and that the series of church
sex scandals could be attributed to
satanic influence or downright
possession the mortared partially turned
down these claims before his death
stating that Cardinals and other leaders
were not immune from temptations brought
forward by Satan who was more active
than ever in his fight against
Catholicism it must be said that a morte
did not pull any punches when it came to
accusing pretty much everything and
every one of being an ally of evil he
went as far as calling yoga race satanic
practice as according to him it is
linked to Eastern religions which are
sometimes centered around the belief of
reincarnation perhaps his best-known
target is the Harry Potter franchise in
his view the Wizarding World described
by JK Rowling encourages children to
believe in black magic and to distance
themselves from Christian prayer however
instead of denting his popularity these
controversies have contribute
- father a mortar becoming the most
famous living Catholic Exorcist and so
it was only a matter of time before he
came face-to-face with the man behind
the most famous fictional Exorcist
[Music]
in 2016 filmmaker William Friedkin
director of The Exorcist interviewed
father a morte for Vanity Fair Friedkin
took the occasion to ask permission to
join the priest in one of his exorcism
sessions his footage of the exorcism of
a young woman called Christina formed
the backbone of Friedkin's latest
release the documentary the devil and
father a morte
when Friedkin met him what he had been
exercising Christina for nine months it
all began with another patient
woman in her 30s whose name has never
been revealed after a long depression
she was found one day by her brother
Paola writhing on the floor her twisting
body shaken by convulsions
according to witnesses she would be
found howling like a wolf and crawling
on walls like a snake this state
continued for several days and a
psychiatrist was not able to help amore
took charge and the patient was healed
after four sessions following the
experience Paola became one of father
and mort's most trusted assistants and
it was Paola who years later met
Cristina mass and he noticed how she
looked distressed disorientated and
disturbed Paola brought her case to
mort's attention according to Mort
Cristina's brother and his girlfriend
were members of a satanic cult and they
may have caused Cristina's Pleiss after
performing an occult ritual whatever the
cause it was clear to him that Cristina
needed his help after following the
discernment procedure the priest started
to exorcise her in August of 2015
Friedkin was allowed to film the ninth
exorcism session in early 2016 clips of
the exorcism session are available on
YouTube and for the most parts I'll
leave it for you to make your own
conclusion I'll just comment on a couple
of things first it's remarkable just how
calm and unfazed father Remote appears
in one clip he thumbs his nose at the
demon inside christina and although the
subtitles miss this my Italian
researcher assures me that he tells the
entity to shut up you ain't worth a
cigarette but you may also notice
Christina's behavior she appears to be
in a trance-like state but she is alert
and reactive to a mots ritual very
reactive as she thrashes about on a
chair or attempts to attack the priest
she is barely held down by two
well-built men then as Mort orders the
demon to leave Christina's body in Latin
the patient replies in Latin
according to Friedkin Christina never
studied Latin at school finally when a
morte asked how many demons there are
Christina's voice turns different
she has been growling and snarling all
through the clip but at this point her
voice sounds double as if many voices
speak from within she first answers 8080
leaders and later we are armies armies
armies then amor concludes the ritual
with a sign of the cross a moat later
confided Friedkin that this case was
particularly unsettling during a
previous session Cristina's entity had
recited back to father a morte all his
past sins this was something that only
the Exorcist and his father confessor
could know immortan Cristina would you
two meet again to conclude the exorcism
but her family kept postponing
appointments Friedkin sought Christina
and her relatives again in August but
was threatened with legal action if he
divulged the footage their concern was
that making her public would spread
Satan's work as Friedkin brushed off the
threats Christina's family ties with
both the filmmaker and a morte
unfortunately the chief Exorcist would
not have been able to complete his work
with Christina even if he was able to
already in poor health throughout the
summer father amor contracted pneumonia
and was hospitalized at the beginning of
September at the age of 91 father
Gabriela and Morse died from
complications of pneumonia on September
the 16th 2016 according to his assistant
he remained alert and jovial to the last
moment often removing his oxygen mask
and to blow raspberries at visiting
friends whenever they started crying
so is any of this real
so far I have presented possession and
exorcism from the point of view of a
Mort do I believe that demons and
spirits can invade and control an
individual well let's just say I'm not
going to answer that what I will choose
to highlight is the perspective of
medicine and psychiatry on demonic
possession for decades since the
beginning of modern psychiatry and
psychoanalysis the official stance was
that almost all possessions could be
explained as extreme cases of psychosis
and schizophrenia in recent years the
diagnosis has changed in the dsm-5 the
official handbook of Psychiatry
identifies demonic possession as a form
of dissociative identity disorder these
are perfectly viable explanations
however some psychiatrists do say that
mental illness can't explain all
observed phenomena and that exorcism
rites can be considered as some sort of
legitimate therapy for example the
British Journal of Psychiatry published
an article on the use of the
anti-psychotic clopin thick ziyal
exorcism resistant ghost possession this
acknowledges that exorcism may be
actually a cure
more recently in an interview with The
Telegraph psychiatry professor richard
gallagher of new york medical college in
columbia university stated that demonic
possessions are real and that patient
seeking exorcism should be taken
seriously well I could go on further
with arguments and counter-arguments
I'll leave it to you so hits up the
comments is possession a psychiatric
illness or can evil spirits haunt a
human soul so I really hope you enjoy
today's video the power of bioethics
compels you to smash that like button
and to share this video with a friends
and even subscribe also please do check
out our Geographics channel if you
haven't seen our video on the vatican
yet and its many secrets
also our fantastic sponsor is Dollar
Shave Club all links to below and thank
you for watching